[Music]
there are good shark movies bad shark
movies and short movies that are good
because they're bad
but what if a shark movie that should be
good bad tries to be good good with just
enough dumb fun to toe the line between
good bad and bad bad does that make it
good what does that make it into the bag
from the country that brought you paper
gunpowder and tea comes one of China's
less important contributions to world
culture as this Chinese co-production
combines native actors language and
values the show touch of a call with a
global appeal of stabbing a giant shark
in the eye while it pulls a McTwist
tae-bong me Jason Statham bird Jonas
Taylor a man made entirely out of
stubble and growls analysts mate isn't a
fight it's a slaughter when an eccentric
billionaire discovers a trench is
actually a slightly deeper dredge Jonas
will have to come out of retirement to
save the crew from the monster shark who
lives there all in the first 30 minutes
but since there's 82 minutes of movie
left he's kidding right strap it in
while the story awkwardly repeats itself
with a hero rescuing two different crews
from two different trapped sobs two
different women set up to be the love
interest to helicopter attack sequences
two different mishaps with crazed
and two bags wait what
they kill the maggot and there's a
second Meg then I just watch the first
movie and the sequel in the same movie I
honestly can't tell that's a bargain or
a ripoff get ready for all the mild
carnage a pg-13 rating will allow with
plenty of just off-camera violence from
a shark who's an extremely picky eater
who just spends time banging into boats
aw come on you have five Meg books to
pull from and the first one starts off
with the Meg fighting a t-rex then ends
with jealous ripping its horn out from
the inside
respect the Meg cannon so sudha for a
movie that sold itself as being
completely over-the-top ridiculous it's
a huge split but got a little too
serious where its own good
try something new so the rest of your
life is Anna vast wasteland of misery
and solitude like way too serious I came
here to celebrate with you and now I'm
mourning with you loosen up you guys
don't worry about jumping the shark
punch the shark and punch it punch the
shark punch it now come on
Vin Diesel would have punched it in real
life starring squint the thin doctor's
Mako oka Ruby rows of teeth ray will
jump Jurassic shark and that Aquaman
poster shut up Meg and we're in
international waters which means legally
could be the elements outta you and get
away with it
can we retire this joke that's not how
international waters work the flag your
vessel flies is the nation of laws you
have to abide by and since the station
is fine the US flag that would be
subject to their jurisdiction now if
they did not fly a flag and they were
more than 12 nautical miles offshore
that would mean you know what I'm
putting way too much thought into this
it's the Meg I got to return some
videotapes no matter how fast you run
Michael Myers can always walk faster
would you like penicillin on your pizza
I'm a Barbie girl in a Barbie world life
in plastic is fantastic